U ARISY  BALDWIN.U R  ME. TN AB
HAVE ABOU BOULD
SHOOTING IN THISN
LIVES ARE LOST AFTER A O IIDE KE
YOUNGEST VICTIM,YEAR
EMPLOYEE AND ATHN 11-YR RAN POLO
NEVE23.
AK.FOUNTAINR ERIC1.VIHOUR WERAR
VICTS G THIS
ACT OF VIOLENCE.
THOSE ARE THE VICTIMS. FS IN
CUSTODY.
A 21-YEAR-OLD MAN. ARE NOWRNINGO
CAPTUR.
HERE HE ISUSTO IS,E SUSPECT.
HEAS LEG, WA
KEN TO THE HOSPITAL.D  TY JAIL L
BE FORMALLD
DEGREE CAVANAUGH IS LIN
UL.Y, SMANYST J NEW
INF
INFI, WHATO OW?
>> Reporter:OR, NOT A
UTE
LEARNGORE ABOUE SUSPECT
WHICH IS 21-YEAR-OLD AHMAD AL
ALIWI ALISSA.
THOUM SYRIA IN 2002.TED TO
HE HIS FAMVE B
LIVING IN THA SINCE 14.BLAKE  SE
TO THE OLDERER OF TH
SUSPECTED GUNMAN WHO SAID HE MAY
D THAT HE WA
APPARENTLY BULLIED IN HIGH
ANTIOCTHN  SAYS THIS MAYE CONTRG
THE SUSPECT BECAME INCREASINGLY
NO 2014.
HE FELT HE WAS FOLLOWED
ANCHASED HE APPARENTLY PE OVE
ON HIS COMPUR TO BLOCK ANYONE
THIGHT HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWINHIM.
THE BROTHER ALSO TOL THET OVERLR
SAME HOUSE AS ROOMMATES.IN THE
DN' HIS
BROTHER HAD SOME GUN BUT
NFUSE
ACCORDING  AFFIDAVIT,
RELATIVE AND SHE SAIE SAW
WHAT LOOKE A MACHINE GUN
IN THE.
THE OTHER ARREST FOR AL ALIWI
ALISSA WAS I2014, HE WAS
GUILO
AT THE TIME.D COMMIT
WEGEAILSF THOSE EM
E RMARKET.
WH TACTIL
VEST, ACCORDING TORITIESA BLAR-
SEMI-AUTOMATIC HANDGUN AND A
PAIR OF JEANS AND A DARK-COLORE
E
ACCORDING TO NEW COURT E UNDERS
HIS CLOTHING BEFORE SURRENDERING
TO AUTHORITIES.
WHILE HE REFUSED TO ANER
RAS
THE AUTHORITIES TO SPEAK TO HIS.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE RAGI
COMMUNITY.FERED BY THIS
KE A LISTEN TO WHAT TH
ABOUT HOW THIS ATE
I FEEL NU.IT'S HIT'S HEARTBREA
VIS, FAMILIES.
YOU , IT'SC.
THIS O HAD SEVENLDREN.
I JUST HADS E FAMILYO WEEKS
AGO TO GIV AWARD PERSONAL.
THIS IS MY COMMUNITY.
E SOMETH THIEN SO  WHEREOU
LIVE, ANTOAR IN
TH
AND TO KNOW THAT OFFIC
SACRIFICE THEMSELVES.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
R
TEPEINTO THAT
DAY AFTERNOON.
TEN OF THEM NEVEMEUT.
WE ARE GRAPPLING WITH E RM
SENSELESS MASS SHOOTING HERE I
BROOKE
UCY NOV IN. CIR TOO
MANY TIMES DURING MASS
TIACES WE ALL FREQ, VIE THEATERW
A
OESSES
E SPKIBO WARD AS  WERE DOINMETH
BR THEIR FA.UST LOOKED AT MY S
LMSITATEJUD HIM,E DON'T HAVE  H
HA
TOWARDS THE BACK OGEERIN THE
W
ON, SOHE U
WHERE THE EX
W TTHCE
HAD TURNED AROUND AND WAS OOTIN
RTGET.
I'FAURD THEN HE TURNED AD,E
ENTERED THE BU THE
HAND ENC A FEW
BUILDING.HEAREOPLE
PENG IN EIR
CARS
WITHIN JUST A COLEMINUTES.
>> WEKEDD HEARCOUPLE MORE SHOTS,
IT A SHR OR  THAT.
IMMEDIATELY WHEN I  KNETHAS SOMI
T
THESE WITNESSES WILLINICE TOGETW
FOTERDAY, EY ROAD OTHER TSPECT J
CHROPOLITAPO W, THANK YOU FO
JUIT.FIRST, THE POLICE CHF
BOULDE TGH -THRDS SHUSED.
WHEN YOU HAVD
D SO WT IS LF W
YTHE ONE TOM LI
THEIR SOS L,YO
YOU D IN
HODE BACK IN MICO, ATHEY  N
AN A POLIC
A LOT OF OFFICERS IN
THE LINETY
ITH THOSE ES,
DEIN
RESULTS FROM THAT KIND OF LOSS
OFE,S SOMETHING YO FOETULD HEAR
VOICE.
TOGETHER BECAUSE SHE'S TRYINTOTT
E.
HERSF E HAS TO TAKE CARE OF
OWRSONAL, THISS HER COMMUNITY,
R'S PEPECTIVE TOOFF RAMSEYS POL
PUT YOUR LE ON THE
AND HO POLICE DEPARTMENT
WITH THE LOSS OOF
OWN?
>> IT'S INSTINCT AT'S
TO PROTECT LIVES O.S THAT MEANST
AND , WHAT TT OFD
WAS TRULHEROICOOK A GREAT DEALH
RS THAT RESPONDED TOHE
ENE DONE T STHING.
CAN'T JUST LETGET GUNNED DOWN.U.
BUT IT IS TRAUMATIC.IT'SAG
I LOST EIGOF
G MY E PHILADELPHIA.'S TOUGH.H.
IN FACT,